welcome to bananamores i can't even
contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
banana bars comedy club my favorite
virtual comedy club
in the world that also takes place in my
living room
yeah i know you guys are excited to hear
my set
i'll tell you who's not excited to hear
my set my neighbor rick that shares a
wall with me
in quarantine i've been doing a lot of
zoom comedy shows
and he'll bang on the wall and say give
up
he's just pissed because in quarantine
i've grown a bigger mustache than he has
so
get over it rick my dad has now i do
feel
bad for him though because i do scream a
lot
i have severe adhd okay
i get excited really really fast
like i was the girl on the roller
coaster that used to scream
right before the drop i'd be like
my friends would be like shut up we're
in an uber and i'd be like
i also don't pay attention to anything
because of my adhd
uh so if you were to surgically cut me
open i wonder how many of those stickers
on those apples you will find
because i just plow through those
because i don't pay attention i get a
lot of words and meanings wrong
i thought the word gyrate my entire life
meant to change the subject until last
week
i was in virtual therapy and my
therapist was like okay
let's dig deep and i was like no no no
you and me let's gyrate
she's like what i was like you and me
we're gonna gyrate
and now i don't have a therapist she was
too expensive anyways i learned what the
word meant
and i've been using it a lot my
roommates used to get in huge arguments
and i'd be like everyone just shut up
and gyrate
i'm gonna go to their rooms and that
would be the end of that so
uh i am in the dating game uh
for women whoa we're shocked now
now it's fun i'm really happy because
the last time
that i went on a date with the guy i was
screaming in the uber over to the
restaurant okay my voice was tired so it
was low
and i sat down with him and he was like
hey
you have a garbage disposal voice i was
like you shut the hell up
and then i left but i had to pay for it
because i do have a bigger mustache than
he does as well
uh no it's not great okay let's gyrate
uh i did do some babysitting in la for
some really bougie families
um you know and what's the best part
about
babysitting yeah that's right rick it is
the food
but in la it's not as fun because
they'll be like help yourself to
anything in the house
and you open the cabinet and it's one
almond that's unsalted
but i found trick cereal at the last
place i babysat for
so i'm thinking yahtzee i grabbed the
weird milk in the weird container from
the fridge
and i make myself a fat bowl and the mom
comes home later
and she goes
i'm so tired but i still have to pump
the milk i used in the fridge was her
breast milk
but the weirdest part was it was the
best
bowl of cereal i have ever had and now i
crave it and when i'm in large groups of
women
my stomach starts to rumble i'm like
okay all right am i gay or am i just
hungry
all right banana morris you've been
amazing rick you've been a hell of a
time
thanks so much i'm audrey stewart i
can't even
get over how much talent this person has
it's downright
unfair they got all the talent and left
me with none
i'm so excited to watch this next
performer light up
the banana more stage get ready for
comedy greatness
okay well i guess i'm here in the in my
own home this is good
this is cool i love comedy i love this
industry uh
okay well i just been inside like
everybody else
you know uh i don't want to equate it to
prison but i've just been in here doing
prison
stuff i've just been doing push-ups and
reading books you know
feeling real bad for the dudes who write
the part of the book
before the numbers start i feel really
bad for that dude you know
just feels like a rough a rough gig to
get asked to co-write a book
and then you find out you're in the part
with uh with all the
the letters you know they're not even
they're not even numbers they're roman
numerals that's that seems so
unfair you don't even get regular
numbers you know
that's like if you get if you get asked
to open for a huge comedian
like if i to equate it to my own
experience if if i did a show with like
dave chappelle then they bring him out
on stage and they're like hey everybody
you ready for dave chappelle audience
like whoa yeah
yeah all right give it up for this dude
that's what the
beginning part of the book feels like i
feel like all of black history is
written in the beginning part of that
book nobody reads that
part just being alone with my own
thoughts you know
thinking too much you know just been
sitting here exploring myself thinking
about
my i didn't know uh my my sexuality
before this but now
you know now i'm now i'm asking all the
questions
you know i took an online quiz that said
i was bisexual but i was like i was just
trying to find out my hogwarts house so
i don't know what that means that
ravenclaw i guess that's
ravenclaw you know
laugh at your screen
our next comedian is also a wrestler so
i'm gonna try to put
my wrestling voice on
thank you misty i appreciate it i'm so
happy to be here
at bananamoors in the middle of a
panorama
which we're all dealing with it's very
stressful
for a lot of people particularly black
dudes i'm tell you why because i was at
target
don't judge me and i was searching for
my favorite cereal
and i looked down the aisle and i saw
another black dude down there and he was
making a decision and it looked like the
decision was really stressing about
right so i felt like as a black man i
should go
and be consoling go down there and put
my arm around this brother
and tell him that look everything is
going to be okay
because this man was buying two family
size boxes of cabbage crunch
okay i don't know if you understand but
you just give up on life if you
bought two family size boxes of captain
crunch okay
you don't care about nothing else ever
in your
life and then there's some people who's
gonna be like well
maybe he got babies he trying to feed
call
dcfs because he don't care about the
roof and none of those kids mouth you
get what i'm saying
he's not trying to get him children
chances to develop for nothing
all their gums looking like big league
chew like it's gonna be okay
get you some kicks or something honey
nut cheerios but not no cap
i mean i get it i get it especially if
you have kids because i have kids
especially dealing with everything in
this panoramic i get it like
but the best thing has been my kids
going to school from home
and it's not just the fact you get to
watch what your kids are learning
it's the fact that uh i don't have to
buy nothing on my daughter's school
supply list
unless you're a parent you don't
understand if you've seen the child's
school supply list it is utterly
ridiculous there are things on here that
should not be there
why am i buying my child six packs of
pigs
just for the teacher to be like well
it's just in case little timmy
can't get some from his mama and my
father looked at me on my taxes
no and jimmy better find his own pitch
with that i don't need to be buying
eight reams of paper
for the whole class because they parents
just felt like they didn't want to go to
office depot i sold them
but like the biggest thing is there's
things on the kids school supply list
today
that make no sense to me it makes zero
sense
more specifically uh a protractor and a
compass
okay nobody's using a protractor in 2021
let alone accomplish who is trying to
make
perfect circles like this in 2021
nobody the only people that are using
the confidence in 2021
are a pilot and a pirate okay and my
daughter ain't flying no planes are
taking over those ships you get what i'm
saying you don't need it
and the thing is everybody remembers as
a kid when you had a compass
you didn't use the compass what it was
for no what did you do with the compass
you would take the little pencil out
throw it away and start stabbing your
friends with a little sticky point in it
now
now i got to worry about getting a call
from my door to school thomas mr
washington
julia was stabbing kids at school and
i'm like oh no what did she use
they was like well she used her compass
i'm like yo that's your fault you should
have added all the school supply lists
it's all been better
maybe if you eat two boxes of cap and
crunch you'll feel better about your
life later
look thank you for the time i'm jay
washington y'all thank you i'm gone
wowzer wowzer wowza doesn't get any more
silly than that jay washington everybody
i
love ya